[Music]
it's another sweltering morning in
Memphis Egypt as the sunlight brightens
the Nile peso Chet checks her supplies
honey garlic cumin acacia leaves cedar
oil she's well stocked with the
essentials she needs to treat her
patients Pez acheté is a Sunu or a
doctor in order to become one she had to
train as a scribe and study the medical
papyri stored at the per ankh the house
of life now she teaches her own students
there before teaching peso Chet has a
patient to see one of the workers at the
temple construction site has injured his
arm when peso Chet arrives the laborers
arm is clearly broken and worse the
fracture is a said with multiple bone
fragments Pesa shet binds and
immobilized as the injury her next stop
is the house of life on her way a woman
intercepts peso set in the street the
woman's son has been stung by a scorpion
peso Chet has seen many similar stings
and knows exactly what to do
she must say an incantation to cast the
poison out she begins to recite the
spell invoking Surkhet patron of
physicians and goddess of venomous
creatures peso Chet recites the spell as
if she is circuit this commanding
approach has the greatest chance at
success after she utters the last line
she tries to cut the poison out with a
knife for a good measure peso jet packs
up to leave but the woman has another
question she wants to find out if she's
pregnant peso Chet explains her failsafe
pregnancy test plant two seeds one
barley one Emmer then urinate on the
seeds every day if the plants grow she's
pregnant a barley seedling predicts a
baby boy while mr4 tells a girl peso
shet also recommends a prayer to hathir
goddess of fertility
when peso shet finally arrives at the
house of life she runs into the doctor
priests assessee she greets assessee
politely but she thinks priests are very
full of themselves
she doesn't envy assessees role as Nero
pay hurt
which directly translates to herdsmen of
the anus to the royal family or guardian
of the Royal anus inside the house of
life is bustling as usual with scribes
priests doctors and students papyri
containing all kinds of records not just
medical information are stored here peso
Chet's son akut head tip is hard at work
copying documents as part of his
training to become a scribe
he's a particularly promising student
but he was admitted to study because
peso Chet is ascribe as was her father
before her without family in the
profession it's very difficult for boys
and impossible for girls to pursue this
education peso Chet oversees all the
female su news and Su news and training
in Memphis the men have their own
overseer as the male doctors won't
answer to a woman today peso Chet
teaches Anatomy she quizzes her students
on the met to the body's vessels that
transport blood air urine and even bad
spirits peso Chet is preparing to leave
when a pale thin woman costs her at the
door and begs to be examined the woman
has a huge sore lump under her arm
position probes the growth and finds it
cool to the touch and hard like an
unripe Hemet fruit she has read about
ailments like this but never seen one
for this tumor there is no treatment
medicine or spell all the texts give the
same advice do nothing after delivering
the bad news peso Chet goes outside she
lingers on the steps of the house of
life admiring the city at dusk in spite
of all her hard work there will always
be patients she can't help like the
woman with the tumor they linger with
her but peso Chet has no time to dwell
in a few short weeks the Niles annual
flooding will begin bringing life to the
soil for the next year's harvest and a
whole new crop of patients keep
exploring the details of daily life in
ancient civilizations with our
day-in-the-life playlists or check out
our patreon page to learn how you can
support our nonprofit mission
[Music]